[Archival voiceover]: It was the same Soviet
story of shrouding their space researchin secrecy.
[Music]
[Narrator]: In 1966, the Soviet Union’s
Luna 9 probe, cushioned by airbags,
successfully landed on the Moon
and returnedthe first pictures from the surface.
Ever since, governments have dominated
the design and delivery of lunar landers,
with the United States, China,Israel, and India all making attempts.
Now, the action is shifting from governments to
a number of commercial outfits that
are trying to make lunar exploration happen
on fast schedules and lean budgets.
Next year, one company’s lander is set to touch down on the Moon
where it willhunt for a critical and scarce resource…
Water.
Astrobotic, a startup based in anunassuming Pittsburgh warehouse,
has received a slice of NASA’s 2.6-billion-dollarprogram
intended to galvanize the private sector’s development
of lunar landers and rovers.
Commercial Lunar Payload Services, or CLPS [pron. "clips"],
is supporting Astrobotic and similar companies
with the goal of sending landers to the Moon twice a year—
along with abevy of scientific instruments.
First up for Astrobotic isPeregrine, a treehouse-sized lander
expected to launch from Cape Canaveral,Florida,
next year aboard a Vulcan rocket.
It will chart a course for Lacus Mortis,
asmooth plain of lava near the Moon’s equator.
The capabilities of the 21 instrument payloadsaboard Peregrine
will be somewhat limited, since the lander will be stuck in one spot.
But it will provide a baseline
for how landerscontaminate the surface with their own gases,
which confounds the hunt for water,
as well as showhow its payload of instruments work together.
In 2023, Astrobotic plansto launch a larger lander,Griffin,
which will ferry theNASA-engineered VIPER rover to the Moon.
Its instruments should determine not only
thetrace abundances of water, but also its origin:
How much of it comes from solar wind
versus asteroids or comet collisions?
Astrobotic isn't the only private company
working under the auspices of NASA’s CLPS program.
Houston-based Intuitive Machines will launchits Nova-C
around the same time as Peregrine,
and another lander—built by Masten Space Systemsin California—
is set to launch in 2023.
If all goes well, the lander program will deliver
a steady supply of experiments across wide-ranging fields of science.
Researchers are planningan instrument to probe the Moon’s interior
and another to snap the first-ever picture of
Earth’s magnetic field from outside the planet.
Even astronomers will hitch a ride,
as a radiotelescope is placed on the Moon’s far side,
where it can scan the cosmos amid a quietunknown on Earth.
[Music]